from spotlighting former Side characters
to revisiting standout villains there's
a reason these stories might feel a
little familiar
supercap is a martial arts action
Extravaganza released in 1992. the film
represents the only live-action star in
collaboration between two legends of the
genre Jackie Chan and Michelle yo the
plot revolves around Chan and Yo's
characters going undercover to take down
a dangerous criminal organization
complete with tons of fights and
death-defying stunts along the way
although the movie was released as
simply supercap and marketed as a
standalone film to English language
audiences this is actually the third
film in a series the original Chinese
title of the film is police Story 3
super cop the first two movies in Jackie
Chan's police Story series were
massively successful and influential in
the Hong Kong film industry but we're
far less recognized and accessible in
the west at the time of the third film's
release in addition to dubbing the film
into English distributor Miramax also
changed the title re-edited the film and
made substantial Cuts totally over eight
minutes worth of footage all of which
made the story of super cop seem less
like a sequel and more like a standalone
film Additionally the soundtrack and
sound effects were changed a new highly
stylized opening credit sequence was
added Jackie Chan's character had his
name anglicized from kakuichan to Kevin
Chan and changes were made to the plot
that further distance the story from the
series that preceded it these days most
people are familiar with the Mad Max
series as a whole from the originator to
Fury Road and all the way to the
upcoming furiosa but that wasn't always
the case it took a while for the first
man Max to reach International audiences
as it was made with the low budget and
only received a limited release at first
the sequel however had breakthrough
power right off the bat and became an
international hit straight away since
Mad Max was practically unheard of in
the us at the time the sequel was
released its title was changed from Mad
Max 2 to the road warrior you want to
get out of here
talk to me the road warrior went on to
become a huge success in the U.S as an
original Standalone film and it wasn't
until later on that audiences went back
and discovered the original Mad Max the
connective tissue between the first and
second Matt Max movies is quite Slim in
the first place so the sequel distancing
itself didn't change much with the first
film lacking the budget to properly pull
off the dusty post-apocalyptic future
aesthetic map Max 2 feels like a hard
reset for the series and barely feels
like it's set in the same world as the
first movie anyway writer director M
Night Shyamalan burst onto the Hollywood
scene with a couple of high quality
twisty Thrillers in the sixth synths and
unbreakable unfortunately his reputation
began to diminish over time with a
string of notorious disasters in 2016
though Shyamalan mounted a surprise
return to form with split James McAvoy
stars as a man with numerous split
personalities who have done three
teenagers one of the teens played by
Anya Taylor Joy is determined to escape
what begins as a psychological Thriller
takes on a supernatural aspect as it
moves along
Ah Holy
this is so cool it isn't until the film
has come to a close that a post and
title scene reveals split to be set
within the same universe as shyamalan's
earlier unbreakable the two films would
coalesce more directly in his next movie
glass
split turned out to not just be a return
to form for Shyamalan but also a return
to his roots as Shyamalan revealed in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly this
character Kevin from splint was in the
original script of unbreakable instead
of bumping into the orange suit Man
David bumps into one of Kevin's
personalities and goes to save the girls
so you'd have been watching the girls
inside of it the whole time
get the trial of Vivian amsilim is an
Israeli drama from 2014. the film stars
the highly lauded Ronin alphabets in the
titular role of Vivian amsilon a woman
seeking a divorce within Israel's
rabbinical Merit system which requires
the full consent of the husband in
addition to giving an incredibly
impressive lead performance Rona
alcabats also co-wrote and co-directed
the film alongside her brother shlomi
alphabets she passed away just two years
later at the age of 51 as a result of
cancer as a festival and awards darling
get had strong International appeal and
broke through to far-reaching audiences
around the world many who watch the film
were completely unaware of the fact that
get is the conclusion to a Trilogy the
film tells what feels like a completely
self-contained story but Ronin alphabets
and previously portrayed the Vivian
amsilim character and to take a wife and
Shiva and all three films were written
and directed by the alphabet siblings
Simon abkarian also stars in all three
films as Vivian's husband Alicia in the
entire Trilogy focuses on the
interpersonal drama involved in their
family and marriage there was a
substantial Gap in time between the
first two movies and the third and get
makes no mention of the previous movies
nor does it require any knowledge of the
characters backstories get them to the
Greek is a raunchy 2010 comedy about an
intern played by Jonah Hill tasked with
transporting a wild unpredictable
musician played by Russell Brand from
the UK to Los Angeles to get to an
important concert on time the film was a
modest box office success and earned the
certified fresh badge from Critics on
Rotten Tomatoes as well received as Get
Him to the Greek was though it is a
secret sequel to a movie that performs
even better before filmmaker Nicholas
Stoller made Get Him to the Greek he
made Forgetting Sarah Marshall as his
directorial debut Jason Siegel who wrote
and starred in Forgetting Sarah Marshall
was not a driving force in the sequel
though he remained involved as a
co-producer Stoller wrote Get Him to the
Greek himself and elevated the standout
supporting character played by Russell
Brandt in Forgetting Sarah Marshall to a
leading role why did you do this to me
out of love throughout his relatively
short stint as a big budget comedy
leading man Russell Brand was quite
severely Typecast something which he
knowingly embraced his screen image
aligned closely with the Persona he had
earlier crafted as a stand-up comedian
and his rock star character in the two
Nicholas Stoller comedies fit snugly
within that Typecast wheelhouse with
bran playing so many similar Rich addict
Playboy type characters it was easy for
audiences to miss the fact that he was
playing the exact same character and not
just a similar one in Forgetting Sarah
Marshall and Get Him to the Greek 10.
be cool
You Don't Know Me Be Cool is a gangster
comedy set in the expensive and high
profile world of the music industry if
that premise sounds familiar it's
because be cool is a sequel to Get
Shorty and kept the same basic plot
while making the simple switch of
transporting gangster Chili Palmer from
the film industry to the music industry
Get Shorty is often considered a
highlight of its genre but be cool on
the other hand has fallen Into Obscurity
and largely been forgotten about these
days despite being a full 10 years more
recent than its famous predecessor even
though be cool featured a star-studded
cast packed with the likes of John
Travolta Uma Thurman Dwayne Johnson
Vince Vaughn Harvey Keitel Danny DeVito
and more the film was a financial
disappointment in a major critical
failure this sequel costs more than
twice as much to make and brought back
less money at the box office than the
first movie with the runaway success of
the original it is a surprise that the
films marketing didn't lean more heavily
into be cool being a direct sequel
though the full decade that transpired
between the two films might explain that
decision one has to wonder if the film
would have been more commercially
successful if it were called get shorty
2 and had been made closer to the
original though the weak critical
reception would likely have been
unaltered although the film was
critically divisive 2005's The Devil's
Rejects was a hit amongst horror fans
and has remained Rob Zombie's most
successful original film The Story
follows three psychotic criminals known
as the Firefly family played by Sid
Hague Bill Mosley and Sherry Moon Zombie
as they torment unsuspecting victims
they are put on the defensive when a
vengeful Sheriff played by William
Forsyth proves willing to break the law
to take them down and he just might be
even more Disturbed than them the story
of The Devil's Rejects is completely
self-contained but this Trio of main
characters made their first appearance
to years earlier in Rob Zombie's feature
film directorial debut House of 1000
Corpses this first film was extremely
light on story and zombies background as
a musician and music video director are
impossible to miss the plot of House of
1000 Corpses is mostly a disposable
excuse to get to the violence but zombie
knew he was scratching at the surface of
something more interesting with the
Firefly family when he Revisited them in
his next film the result was a more
cohesive story and a more mature film 14
years later zombie Revisited these
characters once more and three from Hell
This is 40 is a 2012 comedy from writer
director and producer Judd Apatow Paul
Rudd and Leslie Mann play a married
couple who face a pair of midlife crises
as they both turn 40. while navigating
Myriad troubles in their lives and their
relationship given how simple and
down-to-earth these characters are it
was easy for audiences to miss the fact
that they had seen them on screen before
we're like Simon and Garfunkel and
somehow you turn me into Garfunkel I
didn't know what that means Art
Garfunkel what's wrong with Art
Garfunkel Rudd and man first played this
particular married couple five years
earlier and apatows knocked up the two
were prominent supporting characters who
were upgraded to leads for This is 40
and given their time in the spotlight
the plot of Knocked Up has little to no
bearing on the events of this is 40. and
Seth Rogen and Catherine Heigl's two
lead characters are not present for a
film about aging and looking back on
one's youth it makes perfect sense to
revisit characters that were first
explored on screen at an earlier stage
in their lives the purity of Vengeance
which is also known as Journal 64 was
released in Denmark in 2018 and quickly
became the highest grossing movie in the
history of the Danish film industry the
story follows two detectives played by
Nikolai Lee Kaz and far as far as as
they investigate a disturbing mystery
involving abducted girls medical
experiments and mummified corpses
although the story functions as a
self-contained mystery plot the purity
of vengeance is actually the fourth film
in the mystery thriller series known as
Department Q which are all adapted from
the novel series of the same name the
first three films all contain the series
name in their titles Department Q the
keeper of lost causes Department Q the
absent one and Department q a conspiracy
of faith for the fourth outing
Department Q was dropped from both
versions of its title this title switch
up allowed new viewers to jump right
into the latest movie without feeling
the need to have already seen the
previous entries and undoubtedly played
a role in the purity of Vengeance
becoming the highest grossing entry in
the series by far
2004-2046 is a romantic drama from
acclaimed Hong Kong filmmaker Wong Kar y
Tony lung stars as an author writing a
science fiction novel and the film Moves
In and Out of reality and the fictional
world of his book the title has many
meanings as 2046 refers to the
futuristic setting of the Sci-Fi book as
well as the number of a room where
nothing ever changes which is the
destination of the novel's characters
2046 is also the number of the hotel
room where lung's character experiences
the doomed romance that haunts him and
is the room he currently resides next
door to while writing the book in room
2047 from the outside 2046 appears to be
a self-contained story and one could
watch the film and never realize that it
was a part of a series but they would be
missing out on the bigger picture the
past romance that haunts the science
fiction author isn't just character
backstory it was the subject of Juan Car
Wise highly lauded 2000 film In the Mood
for Love Tony lung and Maggie Chung also
played the same characters a decade
earlier in Wang Car Wise 1990 film days
of being wild though each film can be
watched and enjoyed independently the
full scope of the story and characters
can only be found by watching the entire
trilogy
foreign
[Music]